80 euro und nach spätestens einem tag
das sichere corona testergebnis das
verspricht der neue corona test von
center 7
zuerst muss ich mich für den test
registrieren ich will diesen neuen test
hier heute mal ausprobieren will mir
aber nicht sicher worauf ich da
überhaupt achten muss da ich am
wochenende noch an der ostsee war und
dann natürlich versucht habe immer
abstand zu halten das natürlich aber
auch nicht immer ganz einwandfrei
möglich ist möchte ich gerne sicher
gehen ob ich nicht infiziert werden da
die ostsee aber kein risikogebiet ist
und ich auch keine symptome habe kann
ich nicht einfach so zum arzt gehen und
mir ein test besorgen
roland krämer hat sich aber dazu bereit
erklärt mir zu helfen den test soll man
also eigentlich ganz einfach von zu
hause machen ohne arzt damit ich mir
aber sicher sein kann dass ich den
abstrich auch richtig mache treffe ich
dr krämer er ist kritisch gegenüber der
selbsttests besteht natürlich immer
wieder gefahr wenn man das selber machen
nicht geübt ist wie es das personal was
in den praxen oder kliniken diese test
durchführt man nicht korrekt den
abstrich durchführt dann kommt es zum
falsch negativen ergebnis die patienten
denken sie sind negativ und gehen so
partys festgesetzt oder in bars und
gefährden natürlich viele andere
menschen also der rachenabstrich wird
sehr tief eingeführt und hinten an den
weichen glauben das führt häufig zu
einem würgereiz und richtig ist dass man
das aber durchführt weil wenn man vorne
im mundraum oder an der zunge oben
kratzt dann kann man nicht die
ergebnisse bekommen die man bekommen
möchte beim auspacken muss man sehr
vorsichtig sein den puck vor kopf nicht
zu berühren
dieser muss bei der probe steril sein
das ist der besagte töpfer unsere sind
weiche wartet opfer das sieht mir jetzt
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen nach plastik
aus
der abstrich selbst dauert dann nicht
mal eine minute
heute wollte danach kommt der sparten in
der sammel röllchen also wir empfehlen
eine zeitnahe weiterleitung ins labor
bei uns wird zweimal am tag mit dem
labor fahrer die abstriche abgeholt
einmal früchte um 11 und abends um 18
uhr war ein längeres zwischenlagern
nicht empfohlen wird
nach der beschreibung von centurion kann
der test bis zu 48 stunden später ins
labor transportiert werden es darf nur
nicht zu warm oder zu kalt sein
beim arzt muss man dann oft bis zu drei
tage auf das ergebnis warten zentren
verspricht das ergebnis nach zwölf bis
24 stunden
die abholung erfolgt jedoch auch erst am
nächsten tag so dass sich jetzt auch
mindestens 36 stunden auf mein ergebnis
warten muss und da sind ja auch schon
gleich im thema drin
ich begrüße auch heute wieder den
rechtsanwalt an meiner seite und
kempkens ist uns wieder aus
gelsenkirchen zugeschaltet hallo herr
kempter es geht munter weiter mit
zuschauerfragen wir haben tatsächlich
sehr sehr viel post bekommen und es geht
immer um das thema was passiert wenn ich
im urlaub bin und dann passiert
irgendwas wir fangen wir an mit der
zuschauer frage von petra hügels perger
sie will wissen wenn ich bereits im
urlaub bin und dann das land in das ich
gefahren bin zum risikogebiet erklärt
wird muss sich dann auch 14 tage in
quarantäne was sagen sie also man hat ja
die möglichkeit dass durch den chor ohne
test auszuhebeln sozusagen und den chor
ohne test kann man schon im urlaubsort
machen und die meisten coronet es aus
dem ausland werden in deutschland auch
anerkannt und da gibt es übrigens eine
seite beim robert-koch-institut wo eben
die länder aufgeführt sind die
akzeptiert werden das sind dabei fast
alle ich hab so auf den ersten blick nur
nordkorea gesehen dessen test eben nicht
akzeptiert werden aber ansonsten kann es
natürlich sein wenn ich dann eben nach
hause komme meinen urlaubsgebiet war
zwar schon eine reisewarnung
ist jetzt noch zusätzlich zu einem
risikogebiet erklärt worden das ist ja
möglich dann kann es zu dieser späteren
testpflicht auch kommt eine weitere
frage die sich da anschließt wie ist das
wenn ich jetzt quasi auf das ergebnis
von dem corona test warten muss und das
ist ja nicht innerhalb von stunden da
muss ich dann in dieser zeit mich in
häusliche quarantäne begeben
ja also wartezeit ist quarantänezeit und
wenn das jetzt eben länger dauert muss
ich so lange in häusliche quarantäne
mich begeben also mich auch räumlich ab
sondern zu hause und jeglichen kontakt
vermeiden und deshalb ist es auch umso
besser wenn man das schon im urlaubsort
dann macht und dann hat man eben diese
48 stunden vorlauf eltern auch der test
bei der einreise nach deutschland nicht
sein
wir kommen zur nächsten zuschauerfrage
diesmal von brigitte gold aber sie würde
gerne wissen wie es aussieht wenn sie
mal einen tagesausflug nach österreich
macht muss sie dann auch zum kroner test
an der grenze also österreich ist sind
im moment ja nicht so problematisch
es war von anfang an eine so vielleicht
der wenigsten belasteten länder könnte
man glaube ich sagen wir haben also
keine reisewarnung nach österreich die
reisewarnung für die nicht-eu-länder
gilt ja noch bis zum 31 08 österreich eu
keine reisewarnung und österreich ist
natürlich auch kein risikogebiet also
dass wir im moment kein problem haben
aber es kann natürlich sein dass vor ort
in österreich sich etwas tut wir haben
eine verstärkte masken pflicht jetzt in
österreich seit dem 24
juli und da müssen wir beispielsweise
masten jetzt auch in seilbahnen tragen
das ist für österreich urlauber glaube
ich ganz wichtig und das kann natürlich
immer zu einer beeinträchtigung des
urlaubs führen aber ansonsten bahn frei